نشره الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمدينه كيف انها
قوات الدفاع الجوي اسقطت 11 مسيره من نوع
شاهد في احدث هجوم الروسي على العاصمه
الاوكرانيه واضافت ان حطام احدى الطائرات
الحاقه اضرارا بمبنيين اداريين في حي وسط
العاصمه ودعاء اوليكسي كوليبا رئيس
الاداره العسكريه في المواطنين للبقاء في
الملاجئ مع استمرار الخطر ملتهما روسيا
بما وصفه بمواصله ارهاب الطاقه وافاد
مراسل الجزيره في كي اف بسماع اصوات
انفجارات في العاصمه
اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه مقتل اكثر
من 15 جنديا روسيا في منطقه نوفو يدار في
لوغانك شرق البلاد واصابه اكثر من 200
جنديا روسيا خلال معارك بمقاطعه زبرجيا
جنوبا وقالت هيئه ان قوتها دمرت مقرا
لقياده الاركان الروسيه في ميليتوبيل
بريفيا الجنوبي ومواقع تمركز روسيه في
منطقه تركماك وارجو دار التي تحتضن محطه
الطاقه النوويه في المقاطعه الجنوبيه واكد
الجيش الاوكراني وان القوات الروسيه جنت
خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 60 هجوما من
منصات اطلاق صواريخ على طول خطوط التماس
كما وصلت ضرب البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في
مقاطعه غرسون بيكو لايف زابا روجيه
وعلى مناطق سيطره قوته في دونيتك ولجان
شرقا
للمزيد حول الاوضاع الميدانيه ينضم الينا
من كيف مراسل الجزيره عامل لافي كما ينضم
الينا من خرسون مراسل جزيرت تامر صومالي
اهلا بكما ابدا مع عامر لافي والانباء
القادمه من كيف ما الذي رصدت
نعم عبد السلام يعني في حوالي الساعه
السادسه فجرا التوقيت المحلي هنا سمعنا
اصوات قصف عاليه جدا في سمعه مختلفه ارجاء
العاصمه كيف اتضح بعد ذلك انه وفقا
للاداره العسكريه ان مسيرات من نوع شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع كانت تحاول استهداف بعض
المنشات الحيويه في العاصمه ومحيطها
الاداره العسكريه تحدثت عن اسقاط في
البدايه يتحدث عن اسقاط 10 مسيرات ثم قالت
بان اسقطت مسيره اخرى وللعلم طبعا هي تحذر
حتى الان بان الخطر ما زال قائما وعلى
الناس التزام الملاجيء وعدم الخروج لان
الخطر لم ينتهي بعد طبعا حطام احدى همم
هذه الطائرات المصيره التي اسقطت وفقا
طبعا انا اؤك هناك للقياده العسكريه هنا
في كياب بانها حطام احدى هذه الطائرات
سقطها على مبنيين اداريين في منطقتين
مختلفتين احدى هذه المناطق هي منطقه شينكه
التي نحن موجود فيها الان لكن نحاول الى
المكان الذي سقطت فيه ها او حطام هذه
الطائره المسيره لكننا لم نصل بعض
بالاعتماد على المعلومات التي اتصدرت قبل
قليل من اداره الطوارئ عبد السلام ياكدت
بانه لا يوجد حتى الان اي اصابات او قتله
في صفوف المواطنين جراء هذا الحطام الذي
سقط على اجزاء من العاصمه الاماكن التي
استهدف هي وسط العاصمه ومناطق غرب العاصمه
بهذه الطائرات المسيره طبعا ربما هنا ال-
ال- لابد من ان نذكر بان الرئيس لنسكي
بالامس كان قد عاده وحذر المواطنين عندما
قال بان التوقف عن استهداف العاصمه لا
يعني ان روسيا توقفت عن استهدافها انها لا
تريد استهدافها بل قال بان هذا يعني بان
روسيا تستعد لضربه جديده وبالتالي
المواطنين لاخذ الحيطه والحذر
واخذ كل التحذيرات والانذارات الجويه
الصادره عن الاداره الرسميه هنا على محمل
الجلد واللجوء الى الملاج عند سماع صافرات
الانذار الاعتبار ان هناك ما دام كما يقول
انه انقل طبعا عنزل الاسكي ما دام لدى
روسيا صواريخ وطائرات مسيره فانها ستستهدف
العاصمه وتستهدف بقيه المقاطعه الاوكرانيه
وتحديدا منشات الطاقه ربما ايضا عبد
السلام بالحديث عن موضوع المسيرات هنا كان
قد اثيرا كثيرا في وسائل الاعلام عندما
اعلنت قوات الدفاع الجوي وقوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه قبل اربعه ايام عندما
فاستخدام هذه المسيارات قالت بانه بعد
ثلاثه اسابيع من التوقف عاد الجيش الروسي
لاستخدام هذه المسيراتنا هذه المعلومه
يعني اثيرت كثيرا في وسائل الاعلام هنا
ومن المراقبين عندما يعني وتم تحليلها
كالتالي همم قالوا بان هذه المسايرات قد
انتهت اي ان القوات الروسيه الاوكرانيه
كانت اسقطتها ولم يعد لدى القوات
الاوكراني الروسيه مسيرات من نوع شاهد وهم
يقولون هنا نحن نتحدث عن تحليلات في اطار
وسائل الاعلام هنا بان روسيا عادت
واستوردت مسيرات اخرى من ايران وبالتالي
استانف استخدام هذه المسيارات التي تذكر
في قبل عده ايام استهدفت العاصمه واستهدفت
ايضا منطقه او مدينه اوديسا في الجنوب
واقعت اضرار كبيره بشبكه الكهرباء ومحطات
توليد الكهرباء في اوديسا في جنوب افريقيا
تقول همم اوكرانيا انه تم استهداف نستوضح
الامر مع تامر الصبادي من اخر السنه اهلا
بك
اهلا صباح الخير هل قصف متواصل
القوات الاوكرانيه
القصف لا يهدا في قلب المدينه في القرى
والبلدات الواقعه على خطوط التماس السلطات
الاوكرانيه تحديدا هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات ساعات الصباح
تحدثت عن اكثر من 20 قريه في خيرسون تعرضت
القصف هذه القرى افرغت الى حد كبير من
السكان لكن بعض السكان يسرون على البقاء
فيها رغم اشتداد المعارك بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه بالمدفعيه على طول
ضفتين هاردينيبر في الحقيقه لا تكاد تمر
خمس دقائق او 10 دقائق الا وهو يتجدد
القصف المدفعي بين الطرفين ونحن نرصد ايضا
قيام القوات الاوكرانيه بشحن كميات من
المدفعيه من ميكولايب باتجاه خيرسون يوم
امس واليوم ايضا التطورات متسارعه كما
تقول السلطات هناك وتقول ايضا بانها بدات
تشهد منذ يوم امس انسحابا لبعض الوحدات
الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه من بعض اجزاء
نهر دنبر التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
لكنها تقول بانها تسعى من وراء تكثيف
القصف المدفعي باتجاه الضفه الاخرى لانها
الى طرد كما تقول القوات من تبقى من قوات
روسيه في تلك الضفه باتجاه يعني المناطق
الشرق البلاد تريد ان تسيطر على كافه
ارجاء المقاطعه الجنوبيه التي سحبت منها
القوات الروسيه من المدينه تحديدا قبل
اكثر من اسبوعين اتطورات ايضا والاكثر حده
في زبارود جهاد السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول
بانها بالفعل تمكنت من قصف احد مقر هيئه
الاركان الروسيه في منطقه من التوابل
مدينه ميليتوبيل هذه المدينه التي تنظر
اليها اوكرانيا بعين الربا والقلق تقول
بانها تشكل خط امداد للقوات الروسيه
المتواجده في محطه الطاقه النوويه في
اوليندار السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها
قصفت تلك المدينه التي تتواجد فيها المحطه
النوويه يوم امس تحديدا مواقع تمركز
القوات الروسيه تتحدث عن اكثر من 150 او
من 250 جريح من القوات المسلحه خلال
القضيه هناك قل ايضا
هذه
الحديث الذي تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه
ريف زباله الجنوبي والقصف ايضا يتواصل على
المواقع الساحليه في ميكولايت وفي جنب وسط
جنوبيه البلاد بالاضافه الى اشتداد
المعارك بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
في مناطق في شرق دنيا شكرا